can everyone say hi miss cardi hi
hello guys meet cardi b
rapper actress and preschool teacher
i think carnegie is a good teacher i
don't know
maybe because their last names b
on thursday the rapper dropped the
latest episode in her facebook series
cardi tries and well
this time cardi tries to give kids an
education hi kids my name is
yes it's cardi b but today i am your
teacher so it will be
mrs almanzar cephas okay
yes everybody repeat mrs almond
starcifis
starting with how to say her name repeat
after me guys
ow man
czar stephen
[Music]
that's great well now that they kind of
sorta
almost had her name down mrs almanzar
cephas
at the kids down for a very um
interesting story time today
we're going to be reading about everyone
poops yeah i told you it was interesting
i really like reading everybody poop
because
when i was a little girl you just wanted
to do celebrities poop do famous people
poop
and it's like yeah everybody takes
cardi even went off script to share some
personal anecdotes like
this makes a big poop
a mouse make a tiny poop
have anybody seen mice poop yeah
well i am from a place where there's a
lot of mices and rats
and the poops are tiny and black and
this believe it or not snakes poop too
and they pee as well one time a snake
peed on me yes i was doing a music video
and a snake
pee on me and my friend it's gross
cardi was basically delivering potty
poetry people
everybody poop nobody special poop
everybody got a poo snakes
[Music]
yes and people poop for sure especially
me
but it wasn't all potty talk
the grammy winner also dished out a
history lesson teaching the kids about
the u.s
presidents this right here is barack
obama
he was our 44th president and
this man is so important because he was
the first
black president and she made sure the
kids knew who the new boss in town is
too yeah he's a boss like me cardi b
that's why he's my friend
after history it was time for recess
my personal favorite bacardi
well she couldn't hang come on hey
hey hey you come over here
get down from there right now or y'all
gonna be in the bad table
come on man come on oh ty
oh this kid's bad as hell up next
science where cardi showed the kids a
chemical reaction
that the scientists nicknamed elephant
toothpaste
you know what it looked more like
elephant poop
than elephant toothpaste okay emily i
want to do one bigger than that like i
want to make
whale poop you guys want to make whale
poop
come on guys yeah so
all roads lead to poop i guess stay back
because this is dangerous now i don't
want to
get sued after they blew some stuff up
cardi shared her
big takeaway teachers deserve a really
big race
and she revealed whether she's sending
her two-year-old daughter culture to
preschool
would i ever have my daughter come to
preschool
yeah i mean i don't think the kids are
so bad but is preschool ready for my kid
e.t recently caught up with jessie
collins the producer of cardi tries
and he said cardi loved every minute of
it
she was so into it she was so into
teaching these kids and then they
you know they're they're like
preschoolers so they're questioning
everything she says and it's playtime
outside then it's arts and crafts and
she's trying to teach history
it was a it was hysterical but she was
so passionate about it
that it was a great